[Rob Pike, Google Engineer:] There is a standard problem, especially when you're learning to program.
You have a piece of code on the page, and it doesn't work.
You read it and you study it and you don't see what's wrong.
Then it often helps in practice to just explain the code to somebody else.
Sometimes just hearing yourself say it out loud you'll go, oh, I know what I did wrong--
just explaining what's not working or why.
It's such a common technique that there's a--I think it was a computer center
at one of the universities--they had a teddy bear on the desk at the help desk.
Before you were allowed to talk to an actual person,
you had to explain your problem to the teddy bear,
because chances were just saying it out loud to the teddy bear would show you
what was wrong with your program.
[Niniane Wang, CTO, Minted:] The more you like something, the more you'll naturally want to do it.
I would say do not force yourself to do something, because other people are doing it.
If everyone or if a bunch of people are talking about mobile programming
or functional programming or functional programming languages
or Lisp or front-end programming,
if you try it and you don't like it, you should not try to force yourself to do that.
[Sally Goldman, Professor, Washington Univ:] In the end, good code is code that other people can come
and change and adapt.
[Learning to Program]
[Guido van Rossum, Author Python language:] I wasn't quite that ambitious.
I initially just thought that I need another programming language.
I definitely meant it to be a general purpose language.
ABC actually sort of had multiple philosophies.
It wanted to be easy to teach and easy to learn,
but it also wanted to be a language that was useful for just
slightly non-professional computer users.
I just liked a lot of thing is the ABC language as a professional programmer.
I started copying those ideas and sort of changing them, mutating the ideas
and the details of the language of the implementation.
[Alex Martelli, Tech Lead, Google:] Back when I joined it was the 1.52 version,
so it had been already growing pretty pragmatically for a while.
It was still in a phase of a tumult of new ideas and a general attitude in this small group
of core committers of, hey, one more feature--how could it hurt?
At some point, essentially moving towards the 2.0 release, a sobering sense
that Python wasn't a toy language used by people for their own fun anymore.
It was starting to become the material to build in very complex, important software system.
In the process of designing Python 3, we did actually--as the core Python developer group--
we did a lot of soul-searching and thinking about which parts of the language
and which parts of the library can we improve.
Using def to introduce a function--what does this mean? Define? Define what?
Unfortunately, I have to admit that JavaScript has it right here.
The proper keyword to introduce a function is "function."
Why use--to save four letters? That's not the Python spirit.